the hispanic population continuing to
make up a large
number of those cases here in southern
nevada organizations are helping the
community to try and combat
the cases joe mohler is live in east las
vegas near charleston and eastern to
tell us more about this outreach
joe the hispanic community makes up
nearly 40 percent of all cases here in
southern nevada that's
substantially higher than we've seen it
here in the past especially in the past
few months now on the southern nevada
health district website it is easy to
spot the hard hit areas
in east las vegas including the zip code
89110
there are more than 4 400 cases in this
area
alone 116 from the past week this has
been and continues to be the hardest hit
area
also an area primarily hispanic we spoke
to maria nieto orta from the family of
volta they have been working to combat
the virus
in this area handing out masks and
raising awareness to the
through a campaign she is worried people
are getting relaxed
it's very important for us to keep
reminding the community like hey the
pandemic is still here like it's still
very much going on and the cases are
going up higher every time someone
kind of lets their guard down about it
so it's definitely frightening so just
making sure we're still telling the
community to wear masks
she says they have been doing grocery
delivery service for people in the area
who test positive
so far they have delivered food to more
than 700 people
now the goal is to make sure people who
have the virus quarantine
this tantus manos social media pages
including facebook provide the latest
testing location so if you wanted more
you can head
on facebook as well if you're interested
in that grocery service if you know
someone who could use that you're asked
to contact me family volta las vegas
reporting in east las vegas joe mullen 8
news now